et puis beaucoup de candidats à
l'immigration en grande-bretagne parts
de calais en france à quelques
kilomètres de l'entrée du tunnel sous la
manche se trouve un véritable camp de
réfugiés qui a été créée peu après la
guerre du kosovo un camp se retrouve
près de six hommes clandestins certains
entreront accepté de se confier à nos
correspondants loïc de la mornais
patrick bource dames c'est un endroit un
peu coupé du monde
une enclave à quelques kilomètres de
calais construit à la hâte pour
accueillir des réfugiés kosovars ce
centre de la croix rouge est aujourd'hui
presque malgré lui l'étape relais vers
l'exil en grande bretagne des
clandestins de 30 nationalités
différentes y trouvent refuge
la croix rouge ne leur demande aucune
explication ici nous avons des
tchétchènes
un ukrainien ou une ukrainienne des
albanais et des iraniens
ils viennent ici sans papiers c'est ce
qu'on leur demande je suppose qu'on doit
le retirer et quand ils rentrent dans la
frontière dans les frontières
européennes
pour ne pas que mendy remettre en
question le réseau un réseau très
structuré de passeurs deux filières
clandestines aboutissent ici une
première venue d'extrême orient et de
chine qui transitent par les pays de
l'est contrôlé par les mafias russes une
seconde venue d'asie mineure qui
traverse l'europe du sud où là encore la
mafia s'offrent un trafic juteux
combien avez vous payé pour venir ici
environ 5000 dollars c'est cher
oui c'est cher mais je n'ai pas le choix
je veux aller n'importe où en europe il
ya trois jours la mafia à rançonner des
amis à moi qui venais ici et leur a volé
tout l'argent qu'il leur restait un
voyage long et dangereux pour se
retrouver dans des baraquements de
chantier une détente sous une chaleur
étouffante
certains ont quitté leur pays depuis des
mois nous avons quitté l'irak par les
montagnes pour rejoindre la turquie
convenir ici moi j'ai mis un mois mais
d'autres ont mis deux voire trois mois
ces clandestins sont arrivés ici sans
passeport le gouvernement français ne
connaît pas leurs origines et ne peut
donc les renvoyer chez eux certains
tenteront leur chance dès ce soir vers
les côtes anglaises
là où leurs prédécesseurs les attendent
la lutte contre l'immigration
clandestine thème d'un nouveau
déplacement du ministre de l'intérieur
nicolas sarkozy visite précisément à
sangatte où sont regroupés vous le savez
quelques 1500 demandeurs d'asile kurde
et afghans pour la plupart qui
souhaitent gagner la grande-bretagne où
le régime est plus favorable
sangatte où des incidents sont signalés
chaque jour londres réclament la
fermeture du centre
cela fait partie de nos objectifs a
indiqué nicolas sarkozy sur place
michèle fines stéphanie clark
cette fois le ministre est venu du ciel
une visite impromptue annoncé presque au
dernier moment
après strasbourg hier nicolas sarkozy a
choisi sangatte et l'insoluble problème
de ces réfugiés
je voulais venir
je serais ce que pouvoir comprendre le
mieux
puis pas vous donner le sentiment
j'étais un peu le vôtre que vous étiez
abandonné la presse nationale et
internationale et là c'est le plus
important
la visite sera menée au pas de charge le
comprend qui est celui de pourquoi
sont-ils ici un peu plus loin
le centre de la croix rouge nicolas
sarkozy il reste 5 minutes sous l'oeil
indifférent des clandestins sous l'oeil
agacé de la population qui veut la
fermeture de sangatte avant le jt
mais avant après parce que payent les
pros matinale qui respecte tous les 30
secondes
alors moi tu prends d'accord les
habitants seront déçus le ministre est
venu mais n'a rien annoncé la fermeture
du centre de sangatte peut-être doit
être un objectif mais ne peut pas être
un préalable
dans quinze jours ce seront les
élections législatives ça laisse
finalement
de temps pour engager des réformes
defour nicolas sarkozy le 7
il s'est aussi que la bataille des
élections législatives sera une guerre
de l'image peut-être heureux
demain son fils parlera anglais vernir
nuit au centre de la croix rousse dans
quelques heures c'est le départ prochain
le ter est longue
alors c'est sûr c'est avec nos moyens du
bord mais finalement ça fait trois ans
maintenant que ça se passe comme ça au
centre de la croix rouge et les
clandestins tenait à les mener je laime
temps nous a tellement aidés donné tant
de mal
c'est un message pour son frère à
londres félicite moi j'arrive et attends
moi se cure lui va retrouver son fils en
angleterre vous savez ça fait deux ans
irakien et afghan heureux donc mais le
centre de la croix rouge contre 40 aux
autres nationalités
à l'entrée du hangar des soudaines et
organisent une manifestation de
protestation partagent les gens de alors
que nous formons qu'un seul roux il
devrait nous prendre
de toute façon le centre valeur mais
jusqu'à 6 heures du matin c'est le
départ du tout premier but à l'intérieur
40 personnes des kurdes surtout
essentiellement des hommes plutôt âgées
et familles partiront dans les prochains
jours direction ce centre aéré à
quelques kilomètres désormais ils sont
sous la coupe du ministère de
l'intérieur britannique nous prenons
leur empreinte leur photo nous
établissons sur les fiches de
renseignements et on leur assure un visa
les clandestins ont donc passé la
matinée dans ce centre pour remplir les
formalités administratives
prochaine étape le chateur
et puis neuf jours après le départ des
derniers réfugiés de sangatte la
destruction du grand hangar de la croix
rouge a débuté ce matin les pelles
mécaniques sont entrés en action sous le
regard des habitants du village
christelle sabarot et bruno espaly entre
les mâchoires d'une gigantesque pince
coupante c'est le hangar de sangatte qui
s'effiloche layton et les poutres
métalliques ne résiste pas en quelques
minutes l'entrée du centre est arrachée
visages fermés les larmes aux yeux
quelques salariés de la croix rouge sont
venus assister à cet étrange spectacle
pour eux c'est la fin d'une histoire
avec une adresse unique vraiment unique
chacun sa propre histoire chacun ces
petits moments ces petits coups durs et
je crois que c'est le plus gros coup dur
qui puisse arriver à l'essor du centre
c'est selon moi quoi vraiment je crois
que c'est le moment où on réalise que
c'est que certains
au début du mois les accords
franco-britanniques avait tablé la
fermeture du centre pour le 30 décembre
mais le temps s'est accélérée les
derniers réfugiés sont partis de 14 et
la croix-rouge a vidé les lieux vendredi
eurotunnel qui vient de récupérer le
site a immédiatement entrepris sa
démolition le gouvernement français
était rapide à mettre en place des
mesures pour arrêter cette situation et
on nous a demandé d'aller vite
donc ce hangar devait être démoli quoi
qu'il arrive donc plutôt d'attendre on a
démarré maintenant vers la fin nous
avions jusqu'à 100 personnes par par
jour qui arrive et ce qui était énorme
et je crois qu'il fallait bien marquer
le auprès des
maison de passeurs mafieux que c'était
terminé qu'on ne puis qu'il ne pouvait
plus compter sur un réservoir comme
l'était son gamme
les travaux de démolition doivent durer
une semaine
mais en quelques heures près du quart de
la structure était déjà tombé dans un
mois ce hangar qui a vu passer soixante
huit mille réfugiés aura définitivement
disparu
et voilà qui nous amène à calais après
la fermeture de sangatte en l'absence de
centres d'hébergement et face à la vague
de froid des particuliers ont décidé
d'accueillir chez eux les migrants à la
rue reportage aurélia guima romain
poteau ce qui c'est tous les soirs la
même question qui se pose ou vont il
dormir donc ce soir hier moi on me
trouvera sa place au minimum à l'abri
des regards avant que la nuit tombe
une poignée de cas l'isi un s'organise
une boisson chaude un petit encas mais
le vrai dispositif commence après la
distribution
ce qu'on essaie de faire c'est de
trouver des logements pour la nuit donc
il ya beaucoup de calaisiens ils sont
vraiment en france super eh bien ils
acceptent ils sont très contents de les
héberger pour une nuit voire deux nuit
et si en fait s'ils veulent venir géré
par les médias c'est très bien comme ça
j'observe accueillir de réfugiés dont
mohammad et naïm connaissent déjà la
maison c'est la troisième nuit qu'il
passe ici aux yeux de la loi
l'accueil des personnes en situation
irrégulière peut être considéré comme un
délit
mais la famille refuse de se poser la
question
j'irai j'ai deux invités quand vous avez
les invités ou lors de mon épaule car
d'identité c'est tous les invités y sont
invités - c'est tout donc on verra bien
aux cornichons cornichons jean pierre ne
parle ni anglais ni afghans mais le
temps d'un repas tous parviennent à se
retrouver
jean-pierre nous permet d'échapper à la
police
pour nous c'est l'essentiel et puis sans
lui on n'aurait nul part où dormir une
nuit à l'abri mais demain matin
jean-pierre les reconduire à dans les
rues de calais jusqu'à la prochaine fois
la suite de notre dossier consacré à
l'immigration clandestine
un an après la fermeture de sangatte les
candidats à l'exil vers l'angleterre
n'ont pas disparu les clandestins et
notamment les mineurs cherche toujours à
franchir la manche des enfants et des
adolescents veut
notamment d'europe de l'est ou du proche
orient dont l'hébergement dans des
centres ou des familles d'accueil pose
de plus en plus de problèmes le
reportage à calais de jennifer alberte
et salingue ravis ils ne sont plus
qu'une soixantaine sur ce terrain vague
de calais attendre chaque jour un repas
chaud au plus fort du phénomène sangatte
les était dix fois plus parmi ces
clandestins quelques-uns déclare être
mineur de 17 ans ni 17 nyala maintenant
tu viens d'où et françois voilà d'irak
sait plus comment ça n'a quand même que
je suis venu en bateau là tu as payé
pour vous si j'ai payé mais j'ai payé 50
billets nous 200 dollars en angleterre
il y à plus d'un ans j'ai admiré dans
leur local et comme ce jeune irakien ce
chinois de 17 ans a été interpellé par
la police aux frontières en juillet 2002
puis placé au centre d'accueil et de
formation yvonne de gaulle comme 138
autres mineurs clandestins cette année
tous quasiment aux fugues et dès leur
arrivée lui a décidé de rester j'avais
par le train et tuée était tout seul tu
avais j'étais avec mes parents on n'est
pas de changement angleterre et qu'on
sait c'est que tu te retrouve tout seul
ici quand on est passés en angleterre
avec
60 63 sont deux les voyageurs chinois
passe en angleterre
et puis il ya les gens y passent pas les
gens y passent
et puis je me suis et bien je suis avec
mes parents ses parents ont pu passer en
angleterre puis ensuite rentré en chine
et bouffe au centre yvonne de gaulle j1
apprend un métier c'est pour ça qu'il
reste il a été placé par l'action
sociale de calais qui dépend du conseil
général depuis mars 2002 trois personnes
se consacrent uniquement problème des
mineurs clandestins 366 ont dû être
placées depuis janvier dans les huit
établissements du pas de calais mais il
accueille aussi des mineurs français il
faut donc parfois trouver des places
hors du département
on ne souhaitait pas créer à sangatte
pour mineurs donc l'exemple du camp de
la croix rouge
même si humainement humanitairement
parlant c'était une façon de pouvoir
effectivement répondre à cette détresse
on ne voulait pas faire la même chose
pour les enfants puisqu'on sait très
bien que les réseaux de passeurs ce
serait à organiser très rapidement et
aurait effectivement sucre à un endroit
précis dans le département du pas de
calais il y avait un établissement qui
de toute façon un curé son enfant une
vingtaine de places dans le pas de
calais pour les mineurs clandestins
alors l'action sociale se tournent de
plus en plus vers les familles d'accueil
la mamie qui m'accueille est très
charmante et très gentil
donc je ne trouve pas d'inconvénient
nous essayons au maximum 2 ressemble à
ses enfants et elle au ciel nos plans
comme ses enfants
le nombre de mineurs clandestins à
calais a commencé à augmenter en 2000 en
trois ans 1200 été interpellés et placés
121 font leur vie en france les autres
prennent juste des forces le temps de
leurs placements
avant de repartir politique avec la
tournée de nicolas sarkozy dans le nord
où le président de l'ump fête
aujourd'hui ses 50 ans nicolas sarkozy
qui continue de faire entendre ses
différences d'exposer son programme
alix bouilhaguet marque de la gaine
hagen nicolas sarkozy sait où il met les
pieds
les terres d'une ancien socialiste à
peine arrivé dit
son sangatte il y a deux ans le
président de l'ump alors ministre de
l'intérieur avait fermé le centre
d'hébergement
aujourd'hui la situation les cent fois
mille fois pire
il faut aller dans les bois il faut
aller dans les rues pour voir où vivent
des réfugiés aujourd'hui mais je suis
mal étage
la réponse de nicolas sarkozy à
l'immigration clandestine c'est
l'instauration de quotas
je crois que la france doit se doter
d'une véritable politique d'immigration
je souhaite pour la france une politique
d'immigration choisie et non plus subi
chez les marins pêcheurs ce sont
d'autres quotas qui l'attend sa course
de la pêche des pêcheurs très remonté
contre bruxelles
j'ai l'impression qu'on rentre dans le
système européen bon on n'a plus qu'à
baisser les bras
shiva ou pour les mettre sur j'y viens
alors ensuite vous êtes très en colère
contre lors la campagne pour le oui au
référendum commence dans le nord la
campagne présidentielle également pour
désigner leur chef justement les
adhérents de l'ump de voter
devant les étudiants nicolas sarkozy a
précisé le calendrier et le moment venu
c'est pas 2005
c'est quelque part autour du deuxième
semestre 2006 entre le début et la fin
de décider lequel parmi l'ump est le
mieux placé ainsi joël plusieurs cgt tee
shirt une nouvelle étape
alton le terrain lui est acquis d'avancé
il y a un an lorsqu'il était ministre de
l'économie il a contribué au sauvetage
de l'entreprise
aujourd'hui les inquiétudes demeurent ce
qu'on attend tous c'est du travail et
des commandes le mois prochain
nicolas sarkozy sera en bretagne avec
toujours la même formule magique
il n'y a pas de fatalité
nicolas sarkozy était en visite
aujourd'hui à calais trois ans après la
fermeture de sangatte les réfugiés sont
toujours nombreux dans la région entre 5
et 800 migrants sont encore candidats au
passage en angleterre
nicolas sarkozy s'est prononcé en faveur
d'un renforcement des mesures contre
l'immigration clandestine sur place
mathias hillion le rang des bois
trois ans après la fermeture de sangatte
ils sont toujours là toujours avec le
même rêve passer coûte que coûte de
l'autre côté de la manche jeu en
angleterre
et vous pensez que c'est encore possible
de passer en angleterre un 50 50
mais selon nicolas sarkozy ces migrants
sont beaucoup moins nombreux qu'en 2002
en visite à calais le ministre de
l'intérieur a défendu son bilan en
matière de lutte contre l'immigration
clandestine
la situation s'est arrangée par ce que
il y avait au moment du centre de
sangatte dix fois plus de migrants qui y
en a aujourd'hui donc mon devoir de
ministre de l'intérieur s'était diminuer
la pression migratoire
c'est ce qui a été fait cas de fermeture
du centre pour le reste j'observe depuis
quelques mois une aggravation de la
situation et bien j'essaie d'y apporter
une réponse
depuis le début de l'année le nombre de
migrants interpellés par la police est
en hausse de 14% par rapport à 2004
beaucoup d'entre eux ne sont pas
reconductible aux frontières on a ici
dans cette foule des gens qui ont fait
des demandes d'asile qui ont les papiers
et qui sont quand même dehors et qui
sont loin d'être conductible puisqu'ils
ont toutes les chances de pouvoir rester
en france par la suite
je voudrais que monsieur sarkozy un jour
de ses yeux voient ces gens-là sangatte
ou pas qu'elle ait demeure le port
français le plus proche de l'angleterre
un pôle d'attraction pour les migrants
du monde entier alors sept ans après la
fermeture du centre de sangatte dans le
pas de calais les campements comme la
jungle se sont multipliées sur toute la
côte de la manche
les associations sont formels si le
démantèlement d'un camp donne l'illusion
de régler le problème de l'immigration
clandestine
il ne fait en réalité que le déplacer
france gêne au zoo denis guérin patrie
bullestorm gagner l'angleterre à tout
prix et par n'importe quel moyen
voilà ce qui pousse chaque année des
milliers de clandestins vers calais où
en dix ans les autorités n'ont jamais su
comment faire face au phénomène en 1999
à face à l'afflux de migrants l'état
ouvre un centre géré par la croix rouge
c'est la naissance de sangatte le jour
1500 clandestins se regroupent ici où
ils peuvent se laver ou prendre un repas
chaud toutes les nuits sans relâche
ils tentent leur chance en s'entassant
dans des camions et des par les passeurs
ou en sectionnant les successions de
grillage qui empêche de pénétrer dans le
tunnel sous la manche et ils sont de
plus en plus nombreux l'an 3 ans
sangatte accueille soixante dix mille
personnes en 2002 nicolas sarkozy alors
ministre de l'intérieur décide de fermer
le camp avec l'espoir de tarir le flux
de clandestins
enfin ils se regroupent dans les bois
d'une zone industrielle
malgré les températures glaciales l'inr
les clandestins s'y entassent dans des
tentes
entre eux ironiquement il appelle cela
la jungle je ne suis pas un animal ce
sont les animaux qui vivent dans la
jungle
nous on est des humains il m'a des
animaux aujourd'hui ce type de
campements de fortune s'est multiplié
dans le nord de la france et en belgique
il y en a également un peu partout le
long des côtes de la manche jusque dans
le finistère et même appart à 40
kilomètres de calais un autre camp à ce
matin était investi par la balise
pourtant cet après-midi les clandestins
sont déjà de retour et on est serein sur
un camp qui date depuis la fermeture de
sangatte
il était 10 fois démoli dit fort
construit donc les opérations sont
ridicules quimbert avant que nous
partions armes est un irakien nous
explique qu'il souhaite traverser la
manche que coûte
ici les migrants ne sont pas près de
renoncer à leur rêve
aride et si près du but